all right let's hit a couple of other
small stories related to the uh
politically violent right-wing attack on
Paul Pelosi Nancy Pelosi's husband uh I
continue to really like the tone and
tenor of California Democratic governor
Gavin newsom's analysis of a lot of
these uh realities of the modern right
wing he has been talking about this for
a long time he has been talking about
these are this is a violent movement in
many ways and January 6 proves that so
many different events prove that and he
was interviewed on kpix 5 and he is
making a stochastic terrorism argument
here I'm so glad that he is doing that
he is saying look at what they put out
on social media
look at what they put out at rallies
look at the language that they use
of course people are going to start
committing violence on their behalf
don't tell me that's not any embedding
all this of course it is there someone
who sees it created a culture and a
climate like this
I mean it's it's look online look at the
sewage that is online that they amplify
on these networks and in social media to
dehumanize people like Nancy Pelosi and
other political leaders
Governor Newsom also said he's no
stranger to threats but says he believes
things are getting worse there's no
principle
as three years to come in my inbox
trust me you don't because I'm not
sharing it I don't even share with my
wife
I got four kids so I know a little bit
about this I mean it wasn't just a
recall against me
it was surround sound in every way shape
or form
uh
so love this Venom ah at a level I've
had it look all
there's always folks in the extreme and
you roll your eyes it's just that sounds
with the arena but this is different
this is something's different here
there's you know the mind is being
stretched people feel free to shove
again that's exactly right uh you know
we all talk about it folks in in
left-wing media like me all The Usual
Suspects if you watch any of you know
our other shows if you're in this
ecosystem we all get it to different
degrees uh certainly if one is Jewish
you get more of it we're seeing that for
sure uh but Gavin Newsom is completely
right what do you expect to happen
when you create for years year after
year after year
a culture an environment in which this
type of violence is encouraged sometimes
it's overtly encouraged
uh but sometimes it is more implicitly
encouraged it's knock them around
it's I'll pay your legal fees it's
Targets on their backs and ads it's
someone's got to really show up and show
Nancy I mean just recently Trump at a
rally and others were specifically
targeting her so it's going to have an
impact and if it didn't
they wouldn't be saying it and then the
other really horrif horrifying thing
that we have to understand is
their violent rhetoric
encourages and causes the violence
when it then happens then they use it to
justify more Violence by saying listen
it's both sides are being very violent
antifa BLM and it then justifies hey
we're just being as violent as they are
even though it is of course completely
untrue statistically I gave you the data
earlier